there is the perception of the attempt
to market this current version of
American militarism is something clean
well you know so that the massive ground
invasions of Iraq or in Afghanistan with
200,000 troops on the ground in a nation
building enterprise it ended was became
incredibly dirty incredibly quickly and
you know hundreds of thousands of
civilians were killed but somehow drone
strikes special operations forces was
clean and and we wanted that to be clear
that it was in the case their divorce
has turned into it's been interesting to
watch it on Twitter and other places
turn into kind of a trope and a term
that people a meme that people used to
talk about this because what words do we
have for it it's a it's a borderless
covert war that we know very little
about that happens in the shadows that
people are struggling the name was the
story always about you were you always
going to be the the central figure I
haven't done anything else in my adult
life except except the a journalist and
I don't know what I would do if I wasn't
doing this but I I don't write articles
about me and a lot of what I've done as
a reporter over the years is to try to
go to places to tell the stories of
people that would not be told if we
weren't there and we had always talked
about doing a big project together and
Rick had been spending a lot of time
embedded in Afghanistan and I was just
finishing a major investigative project
on the mercenary company Blackwater you
know we have embedded journalists that
are with the Marines and we see you know
through embedded reporting what they're
doing in Helmand province or Marge or
something like that but then there was
there seemed to be this other war that
was intensifying months after President
Obama took office and it was this sort
of special operations war in Afghanistan
we scrounged together money and and we
rolled very cheap you know we we stayed
in the same room we didn't have any
security and and we started
investigating a series of night raids
and and at first the idea was that I was
sort of going to be just like a tour
guide through this archipelago of covert
war sites we brought in our friend David
Ryker who's a feature film director and
writer and he was really going to just
work with us for like two weeks
I think we had how long was the rough
cut it was for our rough cut the oh yes
we were going to tell the entire history
of Somalia from 1960 to the present
somalia in our original cut was like 40
minutes long here it's for and David
started doing something with both Rick
and myself he was interviewing us and
saying well how did it feel when you
rode into this village what's it like to
be the first Americans these people have
met since their home was raided and
would take copious notes and then and he
didn't make any suggestions in that
two-week period at the end of the two
weeks he starts sending us emails with
our own stories in them and said you
know what if instead of just telling it
through sort of the lens of the the raw
facts of what happened you you bring the
viewer on a journey with you the only
way that we safe for us to work was as a
two-man team so I was you know Jeremy
was producer line producer AAP ke
on-camera personality and and everything
I was director cameraman sound person
like the whole the whole thing I mean
that was we had to travel on a tiny crew
like that because it was the only way
that it was possible with security and
and it produced a kind of intimacy to
with people it was easy to you know it
we created different relations with
people about traveling that way as well
Rick and I were both I think shattered
individuals at one point a couple years
into the invasion and occupation of Iraq
this whole circle of people who had
covered the war and new people that had
been killed I think we reached a point
in 2004-2005 I mean I remember being
with Rick at a bar one night and looking
at him and thinking you know this is a
dead man walking he just doesn't look
human anymore and then we talked about
it later in Rick said I thought the same
thing about you and I think it took us
both both a couple of years to rebuild
ourselves as people to be able to do a
project like this and I think both of us
believe that we have a job to in a
democratic society that you have to have
people willing to go to the other side
of the barrel of the gun and meet with
people that were told or the enemy and
tell their stories in a human way you
know you see these beautiful images of
children in our film and there's one
scene at the end this little girl the
Yemeni girl with those piercing eyes if
you were to blow up her eyes and look at
it what you see is the reflection of me
and Rick standing
there Rick with his camera and me
standing in front of this little girl
you can actually see us clear as day in
her eyes if you blow it up and I've
thought about that image a lot and and
I've thought about it in the context of
the way we respond to the school
shootings you know in Sandy Hook or new
town all of us watched those events and
we know the stories everyone in this
room probably knows the story of that
eight-year-old kid killed in the Boston
Marathon bombing and that beautiful
picture that he had he had drawn calling
for peace why shouldn't we view people
children in Yemen the same way what was
that little girl's picture you know what
were her dreams or aspirations and I
think we don't pretend to have answers
we're not politicians or lobbyists or
advocates you know whenever we go
wherever I've gone you know Iraq
Afghanistan Yemen Somalia you go and the
hospitality in the the well the way that
people welcome you into their lives and
like in him and they people kept the
shreds the little pieces of shrapnel and
bombs and like little you know the all
the material evidence that could gather
they collected and they kept in like a
box and they're in their room and it
kept it there you know waiting for
someone like us to come so they could
tell their story and prove it to them
because they believed that their story
would make a difference somehow and they
knew we were Americans we were from the
country that these missiles came from
and so they believed in us in us as a
country and they believed in America
enough to believe that if Americans knew
their story and had this evidence before
them and could see with their own eyes
what was happening that that would make
a difference